tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates
chaos in Iowa an election laughingstock
it has not gone as planned the only
results from the Iowa caucuses at this
hour are chaos and confusion chaos
confusion meltdown picture adjective to
describe the Iowa caucuses what a mess
this is not the finish that anyone
expected
he's the 2020 election already marred by
uncertainty about the vote count as
chair of the party I apologize deeply
for this plus that deadly virus
spreading far and wide beyond China and
our shout out for the reporter in
Chicago whose stories exposed how and
why tens of thousands of people had to
file bankruptcy over unpaid parking
tickets this is way more than just about
ticket ed this is about restoring
people's dignity from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigate
good evening and welcome and we begin
tonight with the chaos in Iowa where the
first vote for the 2020 election were
cast this week that share of the
Democratic National Committee now
calling on Iowa to conduct a complete
recanvass of the vote after a still
unexplained series of snafus that left
the votes they're still not fully
counted a huge embarrassment and an
election laughingstock this state had
one job
they had one job and they blew it at the
most important time in the election the
only results from the Iowa caucuses at
this era are chaos and confusion never
good here are the numbers as we said
right now they are zeros what a mess
this is not the finish that anyone
expected this is a really major screw-up
it's snowballed into just what was the
biggest political catastrophe I always
seen in a long time several issues with
a new app where results were to be
inputted login trouble reporting
confusion even before last night's
meltdown
people were worried about relying on
this app right but the head of Iowa's
Democratic Party was like don't worry
baby we got this the day before the
caucus we asked a party Chairman Troy
Price if you had any fear about tech
glitches or other problems do you have a
nightmare scenario and if so what do you
do about it
these are probably the most prepared
we've ever been as a party for these
caucuses if we've run through a few
different scenarios but I can tell you
we're ready
this is the most prepared you've ever
been as a party so far it seems more
like a case of incompetence than Russian
or foreign hackers but even so it as to
the already high anxiety over whether
Americans can trust the outcome of the
coming election with the head of the FBI
warning this week that Russia and other
nations are continuing to interfere in
the election process joining us to talk
about this are two people who know a lot
about the issue at Georgetown University
professor bender cannon author of a new
book that comes out later this month the
hacker and the state and from Harvard
Maria Barr silence the executive
director of the defending digital
democracy project at the Belfer Center
for Science and International at
Harvard's Kennedy School miss Lynch let
me start with you what were your
thoughts in those first hours Tuesday
evening when the Iowa results seemed to
have disappeared
well you know Brian I was thinking about
the Iowa Democratic Party because as
part of our work with the defending
digital democracy project we worked with
the Iowa Democratic Party and the
Republican Party of Iowa this fall to
conduct a bipartisan simulation exercise
to help the parties think about
different threats that they might face
cyber threats operational threats
information attacks and it was a great
it was a great show of effort in the
sense that you know some of these issues
are not bipartisan issues and I think
the parties took that preparation
process successfully so seeing what was
happening made me sad for them in the
sense that I know they had the best of
intentions and their preparations bed
boo Canada Georgetown when you saw what
was happening was your fourth thought
maybe the Russians are at it again
well there's an old saying never ascribe
to malice what you can ascribe to
incompetence so I was betting on
incompetence early but I'd be lying if I
said Russia didn't cross my mind and
cross my mind quickly I think for a
variety of reasons it would make sense
for Russia to be aggressive this time
around
and certainly with something as
high-profile as the Iowa caucuses
nothing is more important than election
integrity and cyber secure
so it seems the reason Russia would want
to interfere here and elsewhere we
should expect I think an active
environment this year so yes Russia was
on my mind from the start and is there a
high anxiety about that I think a lot of
people feel like the Russian activity in
2016 went largely unpunished it was a
success for Russia to the extent that it
influenced an election or was perceived
of influence an election and Russia
probably has some structural incentives
to to try what they can again the next
time around the United States has to be
ready for the adversary to come back and
marija a question for you from our
control room from executive producer
Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda Maria with your
project at Harvard you're trying to
advise local state officials campaigns
what to watch out for what is the
worst-case scenario what are you trying
to help them protect against so it's
hard to say what a worst-case scenario
is however we like to look at what are
the evolving threats and needs in this
space so how have officials continue to
prepare and learn how they might
decision make to face these attacks one
area that we believe many people are
interested in learning and understanding
more about are a domain which we call
information operations or what I like to
call influence operations which is the
umbrella of myths and disinformation and
I will say that that we saw as a project
some of this happening during the night
of the Iowa caucuses it's probably a
story that's not getting as much
attention yet but we definitely saw some
some conspiracy theories even around our
project in our work with the parties
spread into potentially we had media
sources asking you know is this true did
you develop the app etc you know we
never tested that our role was to
conduct a simulation that was
theoretical and allowed the parties to
think through scenarios but I think that
that's something we're all still trying
to understand its citizens and voters
what does miss and disinformation really
look like and then what are the systemic
patterns that it that some of these
operations take
I think that's an important piece for
all of us to keep in mind heading into
the election let me follow up on that
was there in fact an effort you think
out of Russia or elsewhere to take
advantage of the snafus in Iowa I can't
I can't say that necessarily and I think
another iteration of these threats that
we're seeing is that you know it might
be a foreign actor it might be a
domestic actor for us we saw it and in
the sense that there were some
conspiracy theories on social media
targeting one of our senior fellows
Robby Mook
who was Hillary Clinton's former
campaign manager and that kind of that
kind of led to this focus on if we
tested the app and so that was just one
small story but I think it's a it's an
important learning point because it's
one of many stories that might have been
circulating online with waiting on the
results and what's interesting is in
previous election cycles some of these
myths and disinformation efforts will
have also been questioning the length of
results reporting in some states it
might just take longer so we need to
know what tactics have been utilized
that are intentional to sow discord and
then think twice about you know is it an
operational problem or is this actually
an information operation going on and
then do Canada Georgetown you write in
your book a great book I'm just going
through it now that there's been foreign
interference in American elections
before back in 1940 that's right so
during the Cold War and indeed before
the Cold War the United States and
Soviet Union were quite active in
interfering in elections and third party
countries but there's a lesser-known
case in 1940 the the British government
conducted an operation to first get
Wendell Willkie a pro war Republican
former Democrat nominated as the
Republican to run against FDR in the
summer of 1940 and then indeed
throughout that election campaign and
beyond to push out isolationist
Republicans from office so one of things
that's remarkable of course is that was
an American ally but I think it shows
that there's a long history of nations
interfering Nieto
actions to try to benefit their own
interest exactly right it truly doesn't
make it right but this is a playbook
we've seen nations deploy before and
Maria you're seeing that already you
expect that to happen the head of the
FBI saying they can't police they can't
be the truth police I think it's
important for us to realize that the
influence tactics happening around our
democratic processes are not just
happening on election day they take time
to build up they happen over time and I
think there are positive efforts
underway to help States and citizens
better understand that I know the FBI
talked about how it would share
information with States on some of the
intelligence and data that they're
collecting and I think efforts like that
help us all better understand the
systemic nature of these tactics versus
the individual examples we have seen as
a project that for elections
particularly you know there are a lot of
i/o tactics but for elections
particularly they'll consistently target
certain things like the wrong time the
type of people that are involved the
location and I know that there are
efforts underway at the state at the
federal level with technology companies
to try and help you know ease the
flagging of those types of issues ahead
of the 2020 election which is great the
rio-são Lynch at Harvard and Bendu
Kennedy at Georgetown thank you both for
joining us tonight thank you thank you
next that deadly virus from China and
the whistleblower doctor who tried to
sound the alarm now the latest victim as
questions grow about the u.s. response
it's going to get worse before it gets
better
that's the word now from the World
Health Organization as it struggles to
contain the spread of that deadly virus
that began in China known as the corona
virus we don't know the source of the
outbreak we don't know what it's natural
reservoir is and we don't properly
understand its transmissibility or
severity to defeat this outbreak we need
answers to all those questions and there
are tools we don't have we have no
vaccine to prevent infections and no
Terra boutiques to treat them to put it
bluntly with shadowboxing we need to
bring this virus out into the light so
we can attack it properly and the World
Health Organization officials also
confirmed today that the Chinese doctor
who was silenced after trying to blow
the whistle on the corona virus has now
died after contracting the virus himself
Chinese officials first denied he died
but now the country's people daily
newspaper has confirmed it joining us
now to talk about this is dr. Margaret
Bordeaux a medical doctor and
international public health specialist
at the Harvard Kennedy School and doctor
let me start by asking you is the u.s.
as prepared for this virus as president
Trump has maintained especially since
the Trump administration has cut funding
for the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention and its infectious disease
research yeah well it's certainly
something that you know we're concerned
about you know how our country is
positioned to lead on this it was just
going to be something time will tell the
thing that's sort of happened that I
think is unfortunate is that after the
Ebola outbreaks in 2014 the issues about
health and health security really got
taken up by the national security
community and suddenly you know health
became something that was framed in
terms of public safety national security
not just a siloed issue
on the side and what was reflected and
their decision-making at the time was
that they created a desk on the National
Security Council that was just devoted
to global health security and what this
administration has done it has taken
folks that worked on that desk and kind
of spread them throughout the National
Security Council under the heading of
biosecurity much more narrowly focused
perhaps on you know bioterrorist threat
etc and so it just hasn't had the kind
of profile that we would like to see now
that being said there are tremendous
people in the US government at the CDC
and the Health and Human Services at the
Department of Defense at USAID you know
have really deep expertise here and we
know that they're involved in daily
conversations about how to manage this
it's really just a question of if the
temperature rises on this if this
becomes something that really exceeds
sort of you know business as usual you
know how is a sort of diffused structure
with no point person leading going to
hold up so that's one concern I think
the other concern that we should really
note here is that funding to our state
public health agencies has fallen
consistently and even our new budgets
that are being proposed you know this
funding for the CDC for global health
security agenda all of these things are
slated to be cut really at the time when
we are most vulnerable as a world in
terms of facing emerging threats such as
the nude Brown a virus so right now is
the u.s. ahead of the curve on this I I
want to be careful here I mean I think
that the right people are talking to
each other they are in conversation of
the World Health Organization I think it
is time that we start you know in
essence China is giving us some time
here they're taking very aggressive
measures to try to control this and
they're buying us a
window where we can start to prepare for
the worst
now hopefully you know this will not be
the worst hopefully this will be an
outbreak that is limited in some ways is
not particularly deadly or can be
contained but we need to prepare for the
worst and pray for the best
right so we prepare for the worst it
would be nice to see you know state and
local agency is really coming out with
messaging for the public about how to
access care if they're worried where
they should where they should call you
they should connect with I and you know
having state public health agency is
really game out with health providing
agencies and hospitals what are we going
to do if significant numbers of people
need respiratory support care which
hospitals are they going to go to where
the respirator is going to come from
where is the health workforce going to
come from and I think we're not quite
there yet in terms of those
conversations or at least you know what
I would like to see and in terms of what
the the preparedness a matter in that
way all right well that's very troubling
dr. Margaret bode our board Bordallo
thank you so much for being here tonight
very much appreciate it up next our
shout out for the investigative reporter
who revealed how and why tens of
thousands of motorists in Chicago have
been driven into bankruptcy because of
unpaid parking tickets
and our shadow tonight for an incredible
series of investigative reports about
what might seem like a rather mundane
subject given all that's going on in the
world but these reports had real impact
and made lives better for tens of
thousands of people caught up in a
system that thrived on the belief you
can't fight city hall but that was a
call to arms for a reporter in Chicago
working for the nonprofit investigative
journalism group ProPublica and it's
Illinois Bureau the ProPublica
investigation discovered how and why
tens of thousands of Chicago motorists
and either lost their driver's licenses
or been driven into bankruptcy because
of parking tickets
yes parking tickets unpaid parking
tickets but a story that at first seemed
hardly exciting - reporter Melissa
Sanchez of the ProPublica newsroom in
Chicago
I wasn't even convinced my editors were
I'm convinced that it was going to be a
significant story and what made the
difference I mean talking to people
whose lives were completely ruined by
ticket debt people like Rachel white of
Chicago whose plight was portrayed in
the Pro Publica stories gas in my car to
get to work or do I pay this ticket do I
pay the light bill or do I pay this
ticket it sucks you know for every time
you make a little bitty mistake for it
there to be a dollar sign attached to it
so you got this $200 ticket which which
is which is a pretty big hit for a lot
of working families and when you don't
pay it on time it doubles that's 400 and
then after that the city sends it to
collections where there's more fees
added on it and it grows to four hundred
and eighty eight dollars and the missed
of me trying to get the money to afford
those tickets they would double so if I
couldn't afford it initially you know
how can I afford it if it doubles and
the investigation found police often
ticketing the same vehicle for the same
infraction several times a week so one
person could have could have easily
accumulated 1500 2000 dollars in debt by
just having a couple of tickets on their
car in like a single week the city goes
after people in a really aggressive ways
they you know they take care of the
impound your
vehicle after you accumulate as little
as two or three unpaid tickets and then
they take away your driver's license and
under Rahm Emmanuel's administration a
few years back the city really took that
to a new level and they suspended more
driver's licenses and they had in years
prior and Melissa Sanchez discovered
tens of thousands of Chicagoans
actually had to file for bankruptcy as a
way to relieve the debt and get their
drivers licenses back I talked to a
woman who had a hundred thousand dollars
in ticket debt and and they couldn't pay
for it but they really needed their
licenses to drive and they couldn't
afford to get him a city payment plants
to be able to start that process to
reinstate their licenses and the only
legal option that they could afford was
filing for chapter 13 bankruptcy forced
into bankruptcy over parking tickets
exactly and then working with Chicago
radio station WBEZ ProPublica tracked
tens of thousands of the tickets and
discovered they were being written
mostly in primarily african-american
neighborhoods and that let us say more
definitively police are issuing more
tickets a disproportionate share of
tickets in the south and west sides of
Chicago where there's more low-income
black families living whenever you wake
up in the morning you know there's a
possibility of getting your car towed
you feel like a criminal you feel like a
piece of yourself is gonna be gone
you know because yes it's just a car but
it's my car but it took a year and a
half long series of stories to get City
Hall and then Mayor Rahm Emanuel to
acknowledge the problem she says it
wasn't until a few weeks before he
ultimately left office that he publicly
acknowledged yes there might be a
problem and we will work to fix it but
now the reporting is having a major
impact Chicago's new mayor Lori
Lightfoot says she was outraged by the
findings this is way more than just
about ticketed this is about restoring
people's dignity this is about being
able to provide for your family this is
about giving people a real chance to get
to work and keep a job and just last
month the Illinois governor signed
legislation
that would restore the driver's licenses
of some 55,000 people tens of thousands
of motorists in the state can now have
their driving privileges reinstated
governor JB Pritzker just signed a law
eliminating suspensions for most non
moving violations it feels really good
and I hear everyday from the people who
call me I ever worked on something I've
had this much impact nice to know you
can fight City Hall that's our program
for tonight we'll see you back here next
week